[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24
consacrait une nouvelle fois à la crise
russo ukrainienne et notamment à la
riposte occidentale joe biden a annoncé
une première tranche de sanctions comme
l'europe qui a adopté à l'unanimité des
sanctions contre 27 entités députés
russes mais aussi contre le ministre de
la défense russe sergueï choïgou ou
encore le directeur de cabinet de à
vladimir poutine berlin suspens le
gazoduc north stream 2 qui relie
l'allemagne à la russie boris johnson
sanctionne aussi trois oligarques proche
du kremlin et 5 banques russes moscou
promet donc une riposte forte et
douloureuse le baril de pétrole quant à
lui a frôlé les 100 dollars c'est donc
une aubaine pour moscou alors quelle est
la force de la riposte occidental ces
sanctions seront elles dissuasif quel
sera l'effet boomerang sur les économies
occidentales
joe biden et les européens pourrait-il
aller plus loin et jusqu'où on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés nicolas massu chi bonsoir
vous êtes j'ai aucun économiste
chercheur à la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique spécialiste des
questions d'énergie auteur notamment de
nrj ressources technologies et enjeux de
pouvoir c'est aux éditions armand colin
en face de vous pascal boniface bonsoir
bonsoir boniface directeur et fondateur
de l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques coauteur
avec anne sénéquier de géopolitique à
tout simplement également avec nos
oliviers à dorgan bonsoir avocat du
cabinet ashurst est également expert en
sanctions économiques on écoutera bien
sûr votre expertise et puis nous avons
avec nous par skype de new york john
rich macarthur bonsoir john rich
directeur de harper's magazine merci
d'être avec nous bon joueur et puis bien
sûr on va retrouver à kiev notre
correspondant gulliver craag puisque
l'ukraine on l'apprend donc aujourd'hui
va déclarer l'état d'urgence le
président ukrainien saluent d'ailleurs
la riposte occidentale les sanctions en
l'occurrence avant de retrouver gulliver
on va écouter tout de suite volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien
la réponse de la communauté
internationale à ces crimes doit être
décisive
immédiate et forte
l'ukraine accueille favorablement les
annonces d'hier et d'avant-hier sur les
sanctions contre la fédération russe
fait par l'union européenne les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne et le
canada
nous attendons d'autres sanctions plus
fortes
l'univers à kiev re bonsoir gulliver on
vient d'entendre le président ukrainien
ils demandent plus finalement encore
plus de sanctions même s'il est plutôt
satisfait si je comprends bien à kiev on
est elle presque en état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence doit être confirmé par
le parlement mais je pense que c'est une
formalité les députés ukrainiens sont
unis en ce moment les rivalités
politiques ont été mis de côté volodymyr
zelensky a dit avoir mené des
consultations avec les leaders de tous
les partis après c'est un état d'urgence
qui met la base juridique uniquement
pour des mesures qui pourraient être
prises de manière très urgent mais ce
sera cas par cas région par région en
terme de sanction je pense que tout le
monde s'accorde à dire que on est loin
pour le moment de cette vague de
sanction inédite que joe biden et autres
leaders occidentaux avaient menacé si la
russie attaqué le cren mais il est vrai
aussi que pour le moment on n'a pas
confirmation que des
véhicules militaires russes ont
ouvertement traverser la frontière et si
l'on fait ce serait uniquement pour
aller pour le moment tant les régions
d'une base qui de toute façon que de
toute façon l'ukraine ne contrôlait pas
depuis 2014 je pense que l'ukraine
s'attend à ce que si il y à une
incursion plus loin en ukraine alors
cela déclenchera très rapidement des
sanctions plus importantes l'ukraine et
bien sûr plutôt satisfaite de la
décision de l'allemagne de déjà refusé
de certifier le gazoduc north wind
symboliquement cela est très important
pour l'ukraine merci que divers gulliver
craag en direct de kiev pascal boniface
or si on fait un point sur les sanctions
un job hayden a annoncé des sanctions
qui vont donc au delà si je comprends
bien de celle de 2014 blocage de deux
banques russes les etats unis voudraient
en fait coupé la russie financièrement
du bloc occidental les britanniques eux
ont annoncé des sanctions contre 3
oligarques proche du kremlin les
sanctions européennes dont kylie a
effectivement cette non certification du
gazoduc on va y revenir assez longuement
dans cette émission et puis également
donc des sanctions contre des proches de
poutine ça c'est peut-être un peu inédit
contre le ministre de la défense russe
sergueï choïgou encore le directeur de
cabinet de vladimir poutine des
sanctions qui ont été mises en place en
coordination avec les américains alors
est-ce dissuasif ou estime aurait pas
dissuasif non puisque sa saison c'est
trop tard pour la dissuasion c'est un
peu un peu tardif puisque poutine âge il
a reconnu ses répliques dont l'idée
c'est qu'ils n'aillent pas plus loin
est-ce qu'il n'ira pas plus loin parce
qu'il eut des sanctions ou est ce qui
n'ira pas plus loin parce que il aurait
plus à perdre qu'à gagner aller plus
loin on ne sera jamais en tout cas s'il
n'a pas plus loin on pourra dire que la
réaction ferme et collective du monde
occidental est venue arrêter poutine qui
selon certains notamment brillé johnson
et même byden voulait aller jusqu à kiev
et donc ce qui est plus que douteux très
honnêtement parce que je vois pas trop
comment poutine pourrait envoyer son
anus cac est comment il pourrait occuper
et tenir kiev et donc on met des
sanctions auraient donc non
c'est une riposte graduée on n'est quand
même pas mal dans la gesticulation en
réalité on prend des sanctions pourquoi
prendrons des sanctions c'est qu'on ne
veut pas faire la guerre et personne ne
veut faire la guerre contre la russie
donc il faut bien faire quelque chose si
je prends un exemple le pape ne peut pas
certifier nord stream 2 bon ça
n'empêchera pas de le certifier d'ici
quelques temps quand la situation sera
redevenue plus normal mais il était
quand même très difficile de continuer à
construire ce gazoduc
le lendemain de cette décision de
poutine donc en fait on a pris les
sanctions qui pourront être relevés qui
pourront conserver mais qui
fondamentalement ne gêne pas la russie
et surtout le problème avec le fait de
désertifier des banques et créera le
risque c'est que les russes construisent
un système bancaire international
différent du système américain et qu' il
continue poutine avait déjà évoqué cela
au forum de valdaï ya maintenant trois
ans continue à vouloir travailler à des
dollarisée l'économie internationale on
va y revenir à olivet dorgan vous qui
êtes un spécialiste des sanctions sont
pas bien sûr ne sont pas les premières
sanctions à l'égard de vladimir poutine
à l'égard de la russie à ce qu'elle vous
semble plutôt mesurée pour l'instant
plutôt quand même exceptionnel est ce
que ça marche les sanctions beaucoup de
questions elles sont assez structuré
assez logique elles sont logiques parce
qu'elle évite le sujet qui fâche ted
européen le sujet de l'énergie
fondamentalement donc elles s'inscrivent
dans une lignée des sanctions qui ont
été imposées depuis 2014 par les
européens et les américains contre la
russie ce qui est assez intéressant pour
rebondir c'est effectivement cette
notion de préparation de la russie et
les alternatives que la russie construit
déjà depuis 2014 aux sanctions
européennes aux sanctions américaines en
2014 qu'on les sanctions ont été
imposées par l'union européenne et par
les états unis on a eu une forme de
surprises de la part de la russie
s'était un peu inédit en plus on était
sur des instruments juridiques qui avait
été un peu raffinée et qui était moins
brutaux que les ces instruments
juridiques qui avaient été imposées par
exemple à l'encontre de l'iran là depuis
2000 14 décembre 2014 poutine dit je
vais construire un réseau alternatif au
réseau swift je vais me retourner vers
la russie
construction d'un gazoduc effectivement
vers la chine pardon construction d'un
gazoduc vers la chine et donc on sent
que la russie même si elle annonce être
publiquement outré par ces sanctions
mais pas très surprise et qu'elle s'est
surtout préparer c'est surtout préparer
joe biden en tout cas a mis en place des
sanctions mesure et on va écouter le
président américain
malines nous appliquons des sanctions de
blocage complet à l'encontre de deux
grandes institutions financières russes
l'aveo b et leurs banques militaire un
premier cap nous mettons en place de
vastes sanctions sur la dette souveraine
russe
cela signifie que nous coupons le
gouvernement russe du financement
occidental
il ne peut plus lever des fonds auprès
de l'occident et ne peut pas négocier sa
nouvelle dette sur des marchés ou sur
les marchés européens dès demain et dans
les jours à venir nous imposerons
également des sanctions aux élites
russes et aux membres de leur famille
direction new york john rich macarthur
joe biden donc a mis en place ces
sanctions mesure et il a fait un long
discours d'ailleurs hier soir d'abord
comment est-ce que ce discours a été
perçu aux états unis on sait que le
sénat voulait probablement aller plus
loin en terme de sanction bien sûr que
oui et les faucons sont ravis mais ce
qui est plus important côté bein et sa
politique
électorale c'est que
ça sert comme distraction de ses
malheurs de déflation
saab est de popularité dans les sondages
et cetera et en plus le retrait de
l'afghanistan qui était beaucoup pierre
très critiquée pas de tous les côtés
politiques dont up by me sens très bien
et je pense que pour sa communication
dans les prochains jours il va vraiment
marteler sa force la force des sanctions
et la force possible militaire sans bien
sûr utiliser les forces militaires parce
que comme
monsieur a dit tout à l'heure personne
de la guerre contre la russie
autre chose c'est un peureux rejouer
revivre la crise des missiles de cuba et
c'est un peu la comédie là c'est le
théâtre de l'absurde parce que vraiment
ce que ce que font les américains en ce
moment c'est plutôt symbolique ya pas
vraiment de force
mais lors de la crise de cuba
les deux les deux pays se sont arrangés
entre en secret pour résoudre la crise
et je pense que finalement c'est crise
sera résolue en secret pour sauver la
face des deux côtés pour sauver la face
à nicolas massu chi la suspension du
gazoduc north stream 2 par l'allemagne a
particulièrement marqué les esprits
alors on sait que ce gazoduc relie
l'allemagne à la russie ses 10 ans de
travaux me semble-t-il joe biden fait
pression on peut le dire se relève chose
chancelier allemand alors justement est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un effet boomerang est
ce que les européens peuvent se passer
du gaz russe dans quelle mesure
finalement la non certification de ce
gazoduc
pénalise-t-il poutine comme l'a dit déjà
pascal boniface tout à l'heure c'est une
non certification sur le gazoduc est
construit pour l'instant on est
véritablement sur un processus
administratif que l'allemagne a décidé
de geler mais qu'elle peut reprendre à
tout moment et ça aussi c'est tout
l'intérêt de l'allemagne en ce moment
puisque l'allemagne est extrêmement
dépendante du gaz russe c'est à peu près
si on prend les statistiques 2020 65% du
gaz importé par l'allemagne et du gaz
qui vient de russie justement vais
regarder un tableau 1 puisque l'europe
est globalement dépendante du gaz russe
à 40% mais effectivement l'allemagne
c'est plus de 50 50 pour cent c'est ça
c'est ça l'autriche 100% j'ai vu la
finlande 80% la france un peu moins
puisque c'est 20% mais du coup il y aura
un effet boomerang est ce que lanières
poutine va au contraire menacé lui de
couper le robinet du gaz
quelque part c'est la déclaration café
dimitri medvedev hier en disant si vous
partez comme sait les européens vous
êtes prêts à payer 2000 $ vaut mille
mètres cubes de gaz pour vous donner une
idée à peu près les votants qui ont été
négociées on est plutôt aux alentours de
450 dollars pour north stream 2 donc
c'est à dire que dimitri medvedev en
fête promet d'une certaine manière une
augmentation des prix quasiment par 4 ou
5 mais la question c'est pas forcément
de dire dans sa bouche que c'est la
russie qui va augmenter les prix ce qui
sous-entend c'est de dire si vous ne
voulez plus de gaz russe vous irez vous
fournir ailleurs si vous voulez allez
vous fournir ailleurs à ce moment-là ça
vous coûtera plus cher la russie n'a
strictement aucun intérêt
de son côté à couper les flux de gaz
vers l'europe l'europe est son premier
client de très loin effectivement il ya
un gazoduc qui en construction entre la
russie et la chine mais c'est un gazoduc
qui est tout petit en comparaison de ce
qui est possible d'exporter vers
l'europe et est-ce que ça la met dans
l'embarras qu'il n'y ait pas de
certification de ce nord stream ou alors
elle se dit ça va être remis simplement
à plus tard a priori c'est plutôt la
deuxième option pour une raison simple
c'est qu'en l'état la russie a déjà une
capacité d'exportation théorique puisque
véritablement l'étudiant ne sont jamais
rempli à 100% etc mais une capacité
d'exportation théorique vers l'europe
qui frôle les 300 milliards de mètres
cubes annuels la russie n'exporte pas du
tout ces volumes là mais ça veut dire
quelle est la capacité dans ses tuyaux
existant à augmenter les volumes dont
quelque part à se passer de la capacité
de north stream 2 pendant un certain
temps ça veut dire que les prix vont
augmenter a priori les prix d'énergie on
est un peu sur cette tendance il ya des
tensions géopolitiques les primes
augmentent de façon donc effectivement
lors de toute façon les prix étaient en
train de monter pour un certain nombre
de raisons qui ne sont pas forcément
liés qu'à la géopolitique 1 la première
d'entre elles c'est le redémarrage très
fort de la croissance asiatique qui
tirent la demande vers l'asie où ça vous
expliquer aussi pourquoi les prix
augmenter en europe c'est un système
offre demande quand il ya trop de
demandes et pas assez d'offres les prix
montent et puis la crise de creux
ukrainienne via si on vous le disait
pascal boniface a priori ça rajoute une
incertitude donc ça risque de faire
encore augmenter les prix en tout cas de
faire en sorte qu'il soit 1 qu'il reste
élevé bon il reste élevé
structurellement il était quand même à
30,40 dollars le baril il y à un tel que
quelques mois on écartons les
directrices semaine dernière on est à
100 peut-être que d'ailleurs la montée
n'est pas terminé et tout ceci pour le
plus grand plaisir de vladimir poutine
puisque 75 % de ses recettes
d'exportation viennent du pétrole et du
gaz donc les sanctions ou l'atmosphère
un petit peu de sanctions l'atmosphère
lourde quelque part profite
indirectement à la russie à poutine mais
pénalisé les oligarques pascal boniface
est ce que c'est pas ça qui peut
justement agir sur l'esprit sur de
vladimir poutine alors prendre le nom de
défense par exemple les bons et les
sanctions personnelles peut-être qu'ils
vont plus avoir le droit de se déplacer
etc mais je doute qu'ils les aient envie
de liens sur la côte d'azur
prochainement oui mais gelé leurs avoirs
par exemple une heure the world
effectivement notamment londres qui a
très longtemps appelé tous les capitaux
des oligarques mais quelqu'un comme
abramovitch par exemple qui est très
emblématique le prix de revient de
chelsea qui a joué hier ça fait
longtemps qu'ils un peu diversifiée qui
l'a pas mis tous ses oeufs dans le
panier londonien donc ces oligarques ne
sont pas tombé de la dernière pluie
commençait déjà à sentir que les choses
allaient qu'ils étaient des cibles et
ils ont déjà rapatrié une partie de
leurs avoirs et je ne sais pas si l'on
dira jusqu'à bloquer les avoirs qui leur
reste de façon il peut y avoir des
interdictions de déplacement abramovitch
à bohain facilement les visas pour venir
à londres qu'il n'avait auparavant mais
une fois encore c'est quand même pas ça
dix ans que et poutine a dit lui-même
entre l'intérêt de sécurité dont ils
parlent des russes entre mes intérêts de
sécurité et le fait qu'il puisse y avoir
quelques sanctions la balance du plateau
n'est pas du tout est égal aux aidants
mesquer moment où ça marche tout de même
les sanctions parce qu'à écouter pascal
boniface il traduit bitrate surtout
quand elles sont qu'occidental c'est ça
le problème c'est que les occidentaux se
comportent encore comme s'il était le
monde entier ils ne sont qu'une partie
du monde et on parle de sanctions
internationales non ce sont des
sanctions occidentales
le reste du monde ne sanctionne pas la
russie et la russie trouvera des
alternatives vous êtes d'accord il ya
deux ans quand elle va trouver des
alternatives la russie ce n'est pas
l'iran par exemple les stratégies de
contournement sont plus simples plus que
de contournement joie je pense à la
préparation je reviens sur cette idée la
russie se prépare depuis huit ans
effectivement je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous on a tendance à
parler de sanctions internationales ce
sont des sanctions américaines au
britannique européenne canadiennes
australiennes éventuellement mais ce
sont des sanctions occidentales est donc
aujourd'hui la chine par exemple n'a
aucun intérêt à imposer des sanctions
contre la russie en miroir donc de fait
les entreprises chinoises n'étant pas
soumis au droit américain ni au droit
européen ni au droit britannique
pourront très bien continuer à commercer
avec des entreprises russes et c'est sur
quoi
vadimir poutine me semble-t-il mise on
se met la chine investisse et en ukraine
donc elle est un peu gêné par ce conflit
est léger mais d'un point de vue
diplomatique mais elle n'est pas gêné
d'un point de vue juridique et sur ce
point les américains se sont frottés à
essayer d'imposer des sanctions à des
entreprises chinoises qui contrevenaient
aux embargo américain je pense qu'on a
tous en tête le cas emblématique ou
hawaï et pour autant on a bien vu que in
fine et les chinois ont réussi à
s'extraire de ces 2,7
extraterritorialité droit américain et
qui n'ont ils ne font ils n'ont
absolument aucun souci à s'extraire
complètement 2 la portée
extraterritoriale des droits européens
et américains dont il faudrait aller
beaucoup plus loin il faudrait que les
sanctions soient mondiale qu'elle soit
plus forte donc là on est vraiment je
dirais dans une première étape à vous
écouter nicolas mas 2 qui pour la france
est aussi un effet boomerang
alors il pourrait y avoir un effet
boomerang si on va sur la question des
sanctions parce qu'on a quand même un
certain nombre d'entreprises là je parle
du domaine énergétique qui sont exposés
à la russie soit parce qu'elles
travaillent en russie soit parce
qu'elles travaillent directement dans le
domaine souverain avec la russie on
pense à total pour le gisement diamal
pour donc l'importation de gaz naturel
liquéfié depuis la russie on pense à
angie qui est dans le consortium nord
stream et nord stream 2 là aussi mais
aussi de manière j'allais dire un petit
peu plus lointaine on a vu justement le
rachat annoncé par le président macron
de l'ex branche énergie d'alstom general
electric qui fabrique des turbines arabe
l on se rappelle du président face à ces
grandes turbines il faut savoir que ces
turbines elles sont aussi utilisés dans
les centrales nucléaires russes qui sont
en construction aujourd'hui donc toute
sanction qui viendrait à toucher de
manière directe ou indirecte le système
énergétique russe pourrait avoir des
répercussions sur des entreprises
françaises john rich macarthur on sait
que c'est joe biden qui a forcé la main
des allemands pour qu'il suspende
justement ce nord stream ii est ce qu'il
pourrait aller aussi loin joe biden que
justement de priver la russie du système
swift parce qu'on en a beaucoup parlé et
c'est effectivement débrancher la russie
du système swift on leur coupe le
système international des transactions
financières là ça pourrait être
envisagée par joe biden il y règne pour
aller aussi loin alors que ça
pénaliserait aussi les occidentaux
mais quand on parle de ligue arc russe y
en a plein chez nous aussi été élu comme
un monde alors il va il va falloir
qu'ils qu'il avance prudemment parce
qu'on veut pas déranger les banques on
veut pas déranger la grande finance mais
pour gagner des points dans la com et
ses bas émigra très très loin parce
qu'il est en bas dans les sondages comme
ici un peu parallèle avec la crise
politique de boris johnson est en très
mauvais état à cause du séisme war 2 de
fait
chez lui au pardon il ya des bruits dac
que j'entends en tout cas il est temps
il est en crise politique
ils voulaient beaucoup changer changer
de sujet
et poutine lui a donné le prétexte
alors maintenant
de passer d'une action symbolique à une
action un peu plus dur
c'est une question de communication
oui est ce que justement il pourrait
s'en prendre aux oligarques dont vous
parlez aux russes qui ont des fortunes
aux états unis en gelant leurs avoirs ou
ce n'est pas encore vraiment sur la
table c'est pas vraiment sur la table
mais ça pourrait être sûr à table on
pourrait certes riffier quelques oh les
gars pour gagner des points dans les
sondages
il ira très très loin pour se sauver
bein c'est un homme vraiment c'était
vrai politique vrai un vrai politicien
de souche et en même temps il ya l'autre
anges des autres enjeux sont sont en
fait très important
l'otan à quoi ça sert notant pour
l'amérique sa sert a dépensé énormément
d'argent dans l'industrie d'armement
nous sommes en train de renouveler notre
arsenal nucléaire
avec des dépenses énormes le budget
militaire
est encore plus grand que bahreïn n'a
demandé le sénat dont vous venez parler
à exiger une hausse dans le budget
militaire au 2o ans au delà de ce que
gbagbo ait n'avait demandé il ya
quelques mois donc il ya beaucoup de
gens qui profitent cette crise aux
etats-unis à l'intérieur du pays donc je
ne sais pas comment ça sera finalement
résolu comme je viens de dire je je je
pense que c'est à dire
ap mais ça ça arrange beaucoup de gens
chez nous et en angleterre au royaume
uni oui mon ami parce que ben johnson
effectivement à quelques petits
problèmes avec ses fêtes et que ça fait
aussi une diversion c'est ce que voulait
dire j'imagine
pascal biche
un autre enjeu qui me dérange beaucoup
et c'est que l'otan
systématiquement étude est utilisée site
est systématiquement pour affaiblir
bonnut alors c'est encore une
humiliation de l'onu vous voyez ce qui
se passe au conseil de sécurité
c'est une façon pour les faucons des
anti onu de dire voilà si inutile de de
fer gouvernants ou décident de prendre
des décisions politiques est sur le
plateau sur le niveau au niveau
international il faut la force de
l'occident et de l'otan pour régler les
grands de les grandes difficultés
international avec des chants et des
russes des chants etc les chinois
méchant peut être rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire
l'oignon versus l'otan fin l'onu c'est
vrai qu'au conseil de sécurité ça ne
fonctionne pas puisque il ya la russie
là son appartement où il ya les annonces
militaire c'est que la suède est
collective ne fonctionne pas les séances
militaires ont été bâties parce qu'il
n'y a pas de confiance dans la sécurité
collective mais je suis d'accord tout
fait d'accord avec monsieur sait que va
y avoir une montée des dépenses
militaires effectivement badiane qui
voulaient réduire très légèrement les
dépenses militaires américaines qui
sommeille de 740 milliards de dollars le
sénat dit non parce que en fait le
complexe militaro industriel américain
est très bien organisé il est implanté
dans à peu près tous les états et donc
ils font pression sur les élus et
surtout on va certainement assister
cette année et l'an prochain à une
augmentation des dépenses militaires
européennes parce qu'il ya un objectif
d'aller à 2% du pib pour les dépenses de
sécurité de défense hebeisen va dire
regardez par rapport à la menace russe
encore plus urgent que d'habitude et la
plupart des pays européens achètent
leurs équipements militaires aux
etats-unis on est dans une course aux
armements en dur fait elle était déjà
forte mais là elle va être encore
relancé ollier d'organes pour revenir
justement au
aux sanctions si si les états unis
pardon si la russie sort de sweex rcd
américain donc décide de couper parce
que j'ai bien compris c'est une
entreprise vous allez nous expliquer
d'ailleurs exactement ce que ces sources
en tout cas vous le coupez le pays des
transactions financières et monétaires
probablement mondiale je l'abordé une
toute petite pression sur suisse il ya
une confusion me semble-t-il entre
sanctions économiques et sweets swift
c'est une organisation internationale
qui depuis les années 70 permet la
sécurisation des flux bancaires flux
bancaires simples comme le flux
bancaires complexes par exemple la
lettre de crédit donc le fait d'être
adhérent à swift en banque ça permet de
s'assurer que les banques avec
lesquelles on échange partout dans le
monde le fonds de la même manière et de
manière sécurisée donc coupé la russie
de swift s'est désorganisée l'univers
bancaire russe dans son ensemble et
c'est pour cette raison on parlait de
préparation que valdimir poutine dès
décembre 2014 et donc des six mois après
les premières sanctions européennes et
américaines à commencer à réfléchir à
une structure alternative le spf s et
cette structure alternative qui est
opérationnel depuis 2010 est aujourd'hui
regroupe l'ensemble des banques russes
et des banques étrangères à ce qui est
assez intéressant et banques chinoises
par exemple la banque centrale de chine
notamment et donc ça c'est intéressant
parce que ça permet aussi de donner une
petite orientations sur justement cet
axe russe chine qui me semble-t-il et je
sais pas si monsieur me permettra de ce
commentaire est à mon sens le talon
d'achille des sanctions américaines les
sanctions américaines les européens des
américains ne sont pas liées comme les
européens par la question énergétique
les américains par contre n'ont pas non
plus intérêt à imposer des sanctions qui
soit vraiment très forte par peur de
renforcer cet axe moscou pékin et au
détriment de la relation commerciale
assez exécrable entre les etats-unis et
la chine depuis maintenant près de six
ans donc il y avait des moyens
financiers vous dit l'alternative existe
assez l'alternative existe parce qu'on
disait qu'en matière énergétique s'était
pas encore tout à fait le cas parce que
ça met du temps avant de construire un
gazoduc en revanche ce système swift
parallèle si je puis dire fonctionnerait
c'est effectivement on sortait la russie
et les transactions donc il existe il
est effectivement il n'a pas été mis à
l'épreuve à grande échelle non coûts
potentiellement on verra si les mois qui
suivent
feront ce canal alternatif entre le
canal préfet privilégié des banques
peut-être un autre point sur l'impact
financier et vous le disiez très
justement la russie se préparant les
capitaux étrangers ont été rapatriés
pour une grande partie en russie les
investissements russes ont été
excessivement diversifiée pour ne pas se
rendre vulnérable à un seul espace
économique et le dernier point et qui
est un point avant semble-t-il vraiment
très important c'est le poids de la
dette ruche qui a été considérablement
la lie des lieux l'idée de bail donne
c'est justement de faire en sorte qu'il
ne puisse plus se financer sur les
marchés laquelle 15 % du pib c'est rien
donc en fait la question de la dette
pour les états unis pour l'union
européenne c'est crucial mais pour la
pour la russie qui se prépare depuis six
ans où sept ans et c'est un c'est un non
sujet donc on est là vraiment pour le
coup dans de l'annonce purement
politique et c'est pour ça me semble
utile même dans le communiqué l'union
européenne via quelques heures qu'on ne
met pas vraiment en avant cette question
de la dette parce que finalement la
question de la dette la dette est faible
la dette et oui foot il a longtemps à
rembourser sa dette la russie a n'a pas
de déficit commercial n'a pas de déficit
budgétaire en plus ils ont construit
leur budget sur un baril à 40 dollars il
est à 100 donc qu'ils ont des réserves
il avait déjà des réserves de 620
milliards de dollars avant le début de
la crise donc en fait ils se sont
préparés depuis longtemps à cela au fait
que comme nous présente les vallières
poutine comme un vrai calculateur qui a
préparé justement de futures sanctions
qui a oui c'est peut-être trompé on sur
certains points notamment je pense qu'il
n'a pas anticipé combien les perdre
l'ukraine combien les resserrer les
liens entre états unis et europe mais le
fait qu'ils puissent hier des sanctions
qui fait que la russie se prépare et
qu'elle scinde et qu'elle prenne son
indépendance par rapport au bloc
occidental ça c'est fait depuis
longtemps qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
mal la plénière poutine aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup de choses qui peut faire mal
à vladimir poutine aujourd'hui ce qui
pourrait lui faire mal c'est là où à mon
sens les américains et de manière plus
globale les occidentaux n'iront pas
énergie matières premières pour une
raison simple on disait tout à l'heure
les etats-unis ne sont pas exposés à
l'énergie russe mais par contre les
etats-unis sont très exposées aux
matières premières aussi il faut
toujours avoir en tête que la russie ont
parlé tout à l'heure de l'iran la russie
contrairement l'iran c'est un
exportateur de gaz de pétrole de charbon
d'uranium de technologies énergétiques
de la quasi-totalité des métaux
stratégiques et c'est le premier
exportateur mondial blé donc même si
vous n'êtes pas exposées au gaz et au
pétrole par rapport à la russie ce qui
est le cas des états unis les etats unis
sont très exposés dans leur industrie
aux métaux stratégiques russes 1 et ça
c'est très compliqué là aussi on parlait
du complexe militaro-industriel
américain tout à l'heure ça peut être
des choses très difficiles à faire
passer notamment sur un certain nombre
d'items très particulier qui sont le
platine et le palladium dont on sert par
exemple pour faire des piles à
combustible économie de l'hydrogène ou
le titane de qualité aéronautique qui
absolument indispensables pour fabriquer
des avions là aussi ça peut être
difficile d'aller pour les états unis
sanctionné dans ce domaine là finalement
c'est l'europe qui est la plus
vulnérable si je comprends bien dans
l'avion 2014 en 2014 après l'élection de
la crimée qui était d'ailleurs quand
même un acte beaucoup plus répréhensible
que la simple reconnaissance de
républiques autoproclamées qui existait
déjà mais après l'annexion de la crimée
par la russie les séries ont poussé les
européens à prendre des sanctions les
emprises mais ce sont les européens qui
ont été vraiment les victimes puisque la
raison ni voilà ce que les européens de
se préparer se prépare-t-il pas mieux
alors pascal boniface qui sur la statue
de dépendance stratégique à l'oeil
volontaire à l'égard des états unis
n'ont pas l'autonomie stratégique
ils réagissent un peu par habitude en
disant on ne peut pas se séparer des
avis encore moins en période de crise et
donc il ya une sorte d'automaticité un
peu des décisions si elle tient devant
des sanctions des européens n'ose pas
aller à contre-courant ils vont les
prendre et ils vont se sanctionner
eux-mêmes l'économie avec le trim et on
n'avait pas le cerro pnv cavaliere a
gricole française nos producteurs de
porcs nos producteurs de lait ont très
largement souffert larry j étais très
fortement votre importatrice avant 2015
elle est désormais exportatrices donc en
fait les sanctions souvent sanctionne
aussi ceux qui les prennent pourtant il
ya un mécanisme de compensation de
l'union européenne en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils ont mis en avant ça va pas
suffire ce mécanisme de compensation
globalement quand même quand vous tirez
une balle dans le pied même si vous
soigner un peu après ça vous fait mal
donc en fait les états unis c'est un
pour cent de leur commerce qui va avec
la russie les européens ont une part de
leur commerce beaucoup plus importante
pour des raisons géographiques
historiques donc il est beaucoup plus
facile
pour les élus qui veut dire il faut
prendre des sanctions parce que cette
époque qui en payent le prix john rich
macarthur ou peut-être rebondir là
dessus ce qui est intéressant c'est
comment justement joe biden voit-il ce
rapprochement entre la russie et la
chine si je comprends bien on voit bien
sur ce plateau que ça fait un moment
qu'ils sont ensemble dans un certain
nombre de décisions énergétiques mais
aussi monétaire financier comment joe
biden voit-il cette alliance entre les
deux qui s'est encore renforcé
d'ailleurs à l'affichage en tout cas aux
jeux olympiques de pékin c'est peut-être
une menace à l'ocs à la commerce
chinoise chinois américains
dans ce sens là mais je ne vois pas les
chinois ils vont prendre prendre le côté
ou défendre la russie ce qui est gênant
dans tout cela c'est le la question du
taiwan parce que là c'est quand même une
question très sensible chez nous et
j'imagine que yahia les faucons qui
conseille bein en ce moment qu'ils
disent
rapprochement chinois russes
c'est dangereux parce que si on perd
mais les russes de dettes d'envahir
entre guillemets l'ukraine ça pourrait
encourager les chinois d'envahir le
taiwan je sais pas si c'est une
si ça fait partie de la stratégie
chinoise mais c'est quand même je peux
vous assurer qu'il ya des gens qui
essaient de faire peur à washington est
de répandre l'idée que qu'une alliance
chinoises et russes pourraient mener à
une invention une invasion de du taiwan
ça pourrait encourager les chinois
oui en fait on parle beaucoup d'un
rapprochement sino russe il faut pas
oublier que c'est majoritairement de la
coopétition c'est à dire que les deux se
regardent aussi beaucoup en chiens de
faïence les russes ont très peur de la
place que la chine est en train de
prendre dans leurs économies voire
qu'elle pourrait prendre dans leur
architecture de sécurité un exemple très
simple c'est la 5 0 hawaï la russie a
été obligé d'accepter l'a50 hawaï mais
c'est un vrai dilemme de sécurité pour
elle dans le contrôle des données et le
contrôle numérique qu'elle veut avoir
sur son territoire donc c'est une
relation qui est tout sauf sans nuage
immital rapprochement sino russes parce
que bien sûr les chinois ne serait ce
que pour contrer les américains vont
venir au secours de la russie diack a
pas de sanction en même temps
reconnaître des sécessionnistes les
chinois n'aiment pas beaucoup parce que
c'est quelque chose qui pour taiwan
c'est vraiment important et puis il ya
aussi le temps on était un peu plus
discret aujourd'hui après justement à
voir ce we à lire poutine devant et il
disons que ils ont quand même des
projets aux-in jean-guy long et prennent
au tibet il en est par ailleurs avec
taiwan et donc le fait de pouvoir
reconnaître des entités séparatistes
c'est contraire c'est à dire pour les
mêmes raisons que erdogan a critiqué la
décision russe alors qu'il est
évidemment proche de poutine parce que
lui c'est un problème kurde et qu'il
n'aime pas que l'on reconnaisse des
entités et sécessionniste mais en même
temps à taïwan certains disent à force
de dire que les russes vont venir à kiev
à force ça fait deux mois qu'on dit
d'ailleurs un coup d'état qui au
règlement fantoche à kiev le jour où il
y aura de vraies menaces chinoises sur
taïwan plus personne de croire à
personne et donc l'alarmisme américain
peut aussi être un danger pour taiwan
parce que à force de dire il y à un
danger les rues sont venir à kiev si au
bout de trois mois ils sont toujours pas
les mises en alerte comme ceux là seront
de moins en moins crédible c'est peut
être contre-productif alors un mot quand
même masquer des sanctions qui ont déjà
marché dans l'histoire celle contre
l'apartheid par exemple oui parce qu'ils
étaient collectives elle était collé
quelques mondiale était effectivement
elle était multilatéral collective
onusienne et effectivement elle
fonctionner même si elles ont quand même
mis beaucoup de temps à avoir la
transition démocratique dans ce pays il
faut pas non plus oublier que des
sanctions contre contre l'afrique du sud
ont aussi beaucoup impacter la
restructuration de l'économie sud
africaine donc il ya eu énormément de
deux canaux internes qui ont été
trouvées pour justement répondre à cet
isolement non on peut dire que là ça a
marché l'iran les sanctions contre
l'iran c'est compliqué le prenne des
sanctions c'est qu'en fait vous avez
toujours l'instrument juridique par
rapport à la politique l'iran a conclu
dans swift me semble-t-il l'iran ils
n'ont pas été en dedans swift entre
2012 et 2016 ils ont été à nouveau dans
swift entre 2016 et 2018 il ya certaines
banques encore iranienne qui sont
strictes et mais pas toutes mes lire on
c'est un très bon exemple parce que
l'iran effectivement on voit que les
chiffres aient l'économie iranienne est
très fortement affectée ça c'est une
évidence pour autant on a quand même un
pouvoir politique et religieux qui
effectivement déclare publiquement que
les sanctions n'ont absolument aucun
intérêt sachant que potentiellement les
sanctions ont pu dans un premier temps
du moins fédérer la nation iranienne
autour autour des autorités après on
voit quand même que très timidement les
iraniens reviennent à la table des
négociations entre essayer de revenir à
la table des animations maîtres comme
premier pré requis la levée des
sanctions donc c'est aussi il nous
paraît légère addictions dans le
discours parce que ça montre à quel
point il est difficile dans la politique
interne de dire que des sanctions sont
effectivement douloureuse et qu'elle
fonctionne mais en même temps quand on
voit qu'on en fait le premier préau qui
on peut légitimement se poser la
question de leur efficacité est de
savoir dans quelle mesure c'est parce
qu'elles n'ont plus permis environ de
développer de manière outrancière son
programme il est clair donc difficile de
comparer l'iran et la russie c'est pas
du tout la même chose dépendance et
comme la lolita la même taille même les
relations historiques fin l'europe et la
russie s'est quand même des partenaires
historiques depuis des millénaires en
fait on est vraiment dans des histoires
communes donc les flux commerciaux
reflète cette histoire commune l'iran
est un partenaire important et est un
partenaire important de l'union
européenne mais beaucoup moins que la
russie on peut prendre l'exemple du
venezuela les sanctions effectivement
pénalise le venezuela mais il pas knees
la population et maduro est toujours au
pouvoir malgré tout les sanctions qui
ont été prises contre lui donc très
souvent quand même les sanctions sont
plutôt à destination de l'opinion
publique du pays qui prend les sanctions
peuvent être regardés on fait quelque
chose on se laisse pas faire mais très
souvent c'est plutôt la population qui
souffre et le régime lui il épargné par
les sanctions le fait que ça peut bien
sûr souffre très souvent c'est vraiment
pas sa préoccupation première c'est
l'une des régimes très autoritaire et
les régimes s'en sortent il n'y a pas
pour l'instant de régime qui soit tombée
sous le sofa l'apartheid quand même ça
c'est le seul complice et alors là il y
avait une décision de des nations-unies
effectivement c'était global john rich
vous voulez je n'écris pas qu'arthur
justement joué juste très vite a ajouté
il ya des sanctions il ya six ans que
les sanctions et les sanctions qu'on a
a manqué contre l'irak et sa mousse et
ont fait crever de faim des milliers et
des milliers de personnes qui a tué des
enfants c'était l'horreur cette époque
de clint de l'ère clinton mais c'est la
fin ça n'a pas fait tomber sa de ramos
et alors il faut faire des décide faire
des distinctions entre sanctions faut
faire cette action tend son bras un
petit mot de conclusion nicolas massu
qui donc les prix de l'énergie a priori
vont augmenter vont rester élevés
j'allais dire qu'il ya bien malin qui
pourra vous le dire donc toi voilà a
priori comme effectivement on est dans
une situation géopolitique tendu on est
dans une situation d'offre faible par
rapport à une demande élevée a priori
les prix devraient continuer à augmenter
surtout qu'on est dans une période
d'instabilité et d'insécurité des
marchés et c'est ce que les marchés
détestent le plus
le pouvoir d'achat va revenir dans la
campagne présidentielle française pour
ramener un petit peu oui et on est dans
une période longue de tension je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait une guerre je ne
crois pas que les rues cei à kiev mais
le fait qu'ils aient un règlement qui
permettent un peu de revenir et une
période plus calme n'est pas pour demain
voyez dorgan n'ai rien su la vraie
question c'est pour moi ce sera la
sortie des sanctions parce que on ne le
dit pas suffisamment les sanctions
européennes ont une durée qui est
annuelle et qui est renouvelé par
décision unanime des 27 états membres je
me pose la question de savoir ce qui se
passe si poutine ne va pas plus loin que
les régions indépendantiste est-ce qu'on
conserve des sanctions est ce qu'on les
perdrais est ce qu'elle est ce qu on les
maintient ou pas pour moi c'est l'enjeu
assez rapidement on va se poser sur la
question de la survie des sanctions une
fois cette crise passée la survie des
sons john drake macarthur à notre
conclusion est très vite ce que je
trouve que ce que je regrette dans tout
cela assez c'est le manque de débat sur
la raison d'être de l'otan il ya 30 ans
il ya des gens bien qui disait peut-être
ces bons moments de désamorcer l'otan ou
même de le liquider à quoi ça sert de
temps là il est là il a retrouvé une
ville à l'autre on peut le dire dans
cette crise et alors on fait on fait
revivre le or à nîmes
le temps sans comprendre vraiment
pourquoi à quoi ça sert est ce que c'est
vraiment un système pour contourner ou
pour empêcher une invasion de l'europe
par la russie absurde c'est encore une
question donc vous conclurez avec cette
question versé beaucoup john rich
macarthur d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de new york merci pascal boniface
merci à vous olivier dorgan merci
nicolas mas zucchi et puis merci à vous
tous de nous avoir si vous restez avec
nous et sur france 24